on the hill today for the friars just
chris paddock well it all starts today
at petco park trying to sweep these
diamondbacks chris paddock tried to
forget about last season 12 starts the
4-5 record the era just under 5.
there's a grounder right side they're in
the shift it's crawlingworth who throws
out rojas
two on for peralta let's see if the
cleanup hitter for the diamondbacks can
come through on the clutch here
the change up out over the plate that's
a fair ball down the line martay will
score walker headed for third and
they're gonna wave him home the freight
train is in there with a two-run triple
one out and peralta at third base
oh two is grounded softly to first
osmore looks the runner back and he'll
apply the tag here
as cabrera heads back to the dugout i
guess he doesn't need to
he's inching his way down now
and a swing of the miss paddy comes back
to strikeout smith
and your ram truck starting pitcher is
the right-hander taylor widener 26 years
old
and a dozen relief appearances last year
in his first big league experience and
today makes his first career start will
myers in right luis campusano doing the
catching
matisse swings at the first pitch sky to
center for cattell fighting the sun
off of taylor nice recovery there
and they just do get him at first
[Applause]
trying to punt his way on taylor widener
terrific play and he works a one two
three first inning
but over the course of the long haul
you gotta locate nice change swing and a
miss and he strikes out widener and it's
first and third with nobody out here in
the second and eight
right there at 94. there's the down
fastball and widener gets his first
strikeout
sticks with the heat no throw down there
no throw through for carson kelly as fam
sneaks in but camposano strikes out and
that's two outs
from taylor winder on the way and got
him looking and the side is retired
of the foul ticking of the catchers
meant for strike three
needed that third strikeout for paddock
on the afternoon needed that is right
big time now with one out here's peralta
who tripled into the right field corner
in the first sending to give the
dimebags are two nothing later gotta
think of these things
osmore will go to second they get a one
and they can't turn two it kicks away
here comes rojas and it's three nothing
fernando tatis junior already has three
errors in this series now you can't
assume a double play here
his defense been a little sketchy so far
hosmer plenty of time
and then this is one where you know
tatis probably should have just put it
in his back pocket
carson wants it down
good spot great slider from taylor
widener and he puts hosmer away
strikeout number four
45 pitches 33 for strikes fastball on
the ground per domo
go get it young man geraldo perdomo
welcome to the major leagues
tell you what that was beautiful that
ball was hit hard he dives to his left
immediately gets up and then guns him
accurately
[Applause]
and posada lines one to right field
pavon smith with a terrific running grab
to take away extra basis that ball is
slicing away from him off the bat of a
right-handed hitter but he keeps his eye
on the ball never breaks stride reaches
up and takes extra bases away from
campasano so you got pro far at second
base tanteis at first kronerworth now
all of a sudden represents the time run
for san diego here in the fifth inning
here's the pitch
and a pop fly
center field marte coming on cattell is
there he's two hands it yeah the inning
comes to an end widener today has made
the pitches when he's needed to
snap back the throw from the catcher
see if he makes an adjustment right here
he went around and strikes out
chris matt picks up the k two down here
in the sixth inning
swing and a miss
christmas strikes him out david
widener's first ever major league start
has been outstanding so far
here's a 3-2 and got him looking good
pitch
and he did get the
box
osmore kind of bends over he's rung up
and that's odd number one
pitch to myers is hit
into right looks like there's a play for
smith pavin is under it
and has it
and widener six shutout innings in san
diego
on the ground to third base machado goes
to second for one
[Applause]
and he'll tell you frankly that he does
not have the ability to get that big
four-seam fastball up in the zone and
overpower guys so he needs ground balls
rojas got him
josh rojas with a terrific stop on that
grounder behind crichton and that's out
number one big play right there you do
not want to give the padres any sense of
momentum here in a three to nothing
ballgame what a great play by josh rojos
the one hopper this time does not hit
christian walker in the face instead he
picks it cleanly for the first half
there it is right there finally throwing
that sinker and rings up matteo for
round number two three to nothing on top
the diamondbacks with alex young coming
into the game the padres threatening
and there's a fly ball
into right haven smith's got a beat on
it under it and
makes a catch
that'll end the inning so nice job by
young crichton they get the job done
elevates and he strikes him out first k
for tim hill is out number two of the
eighth inning
at the corners with two down and this
one grounded back to the mound hill's
got it he'll flip underhanded to first
and that is that in the top of the 8th
inning and now ginkgo gets the call here
candy and mean that third out to keep
this a three-nothing ball game walking
off the mound
bam is at third meyers at first here's
the pitch from ginkgo and strike three
call got him looking gingle comes on
throws three pitches
and strikes out the catcher camp husano
right-hander chris davinski on for the
save and his diamondback debut
shift is on cabrera is there ground ball
retired
one away in the ninth
little tapper
cabrera from the shadows
two down
batteries are down to their final out
here in the bottom of the ninth inning
and fernando tatis junior coming up to
try and extend it
high drive to deep left center field for
fernando tatis jr homerun
fernando's first of 2021 gets the padres
on the board in the night it's a
fastball
right down the middle and he knew it
everybody in the ballpark knew it even
the outfielders peralta martay they just
gave it the old courtesy look
time for a new baseball
a little tap her over the mound up the
middle
diamondbacks get win number one in 2021
davinski nails it down